when you're gaming as a career it can be
really really stressful this is how
unforgiving game and all forgiving scene
if you don't perform well then maybe you
won't have a job next year we are beyond
the summit studio / house we have about
two hundred and eighty thousand dollar
prize pool at the moment the six best
teams in the world competing five of us
live here all year round for the most
part we are commentators and content
creators the teams to set up there
playing rooms in our bedrooms which is
what kind of makes event unique that we
have this kind of personal feel to it
where the teams will feel very
comfortable can just relax have a good
time we're here at the summit 3 what day
is it I don't know the day - okay
and like then and like this 30-game
how's it going they know pretty good
I'm jacket TN and the team owner of
cloud 9
I started with one team and now I'm at
ten teams I've been watching he sports
grow and the level of interest and
corporate sponsorships some
multi-billion dollar companies are
behind us Intel Dell Alienware they
can't get enough of it it's like people
only do things because they get paid and
that's just really sad contractor no I
won't bow to any sponsor most eSport
gamers are 19 to 23 years old that's
like the pride attempt where you decide
like where you want to go for the rest
of your life it's such a simple job and
become so confident communication this
is my teamwork how to like work is
difficult situations way under extreme
pressure in front of huge audiences
these type of life experiences I have
like a 17 year old night robust you
can't actually get the prize pools are
do they sound we just play for fun
the biggest event every year valve hosts
the International last year in 2014 it
could up to ten million dollars first
place walking away with a bit over five
million dollars there are some
millionaires in the house right now
that won last year I street fun because
I love to play the video games now I'm
getting paid for it
apocalypse neo Genesis we want the most
money besides the International for
individually which gained like 300,000
we started to make really good money
my brother started playing at first and
then I started playing [ __ ] when I was
little kid I'd like come home from
school my friends would come on my 3:30
we just played dota but then they
dropped off when they graduated so now
I'm like the solo dota player and my
crew
it's always weird when you check your
facebook fanpage and let people see you
I love you so much please like send me
your hair that's very weird but you know
I appreciate it
in the dota world I'm definitely pretty
famous most often I like at events will
get a lot of fans and people that make
us feel like movie stars when I meet
fans they come up that either be
screaming my nickname Big Daddy
from he's hilarious we have like a
thumper you come to our houses we can't
have them film outside of the house
because even if they blur the address
there will be people that will hop on
Google Maps they'll go street by street
trying to identify like the shape of
that house they'll show up it began as a
hobby for pretty much all of them but
it's become a dream come true they are
living professionals you get to compete
on these teams